[Musique]
il ya un certain nombre de choses sur
lesquelles nous sommes fermement opposés
il ya un certain nombre de dérives qui a
eu sur les questions sociales
économiques mais aussi terry talent et
puis sur la question également de la
lutte contre l'islamisme radical et que
donc ce que nous attendons du
gouvernement ce ne sont pas simplement
comme j'ai dit des paroles mais ce sont
des actes si emmanuel macron faisait
vraiment une réforme à chaque fois qu'il
annonçait une réforme
il serait sans doute l'un des plus
grands réformateurs de la vème
république il est hélas très loin de
cela c'est un brillant storyteller c'est
un formidable communicants c'est en
revanche un piètre réformateur
aujourd'hui les résultats sont pas au
rendez vous nous sur le plan social la
sphère du gilet jaune montre bien qu'il
ya une fracture sociale dans notre pays
même si c'est à coup d'arsys même ça a
coûté une vingtaine de milliards et même
ça plombe les déficits
ben vous avez vous avez donné vous même
la réponse est le deuxième et sans qui
une autorité de l'état qui se soit
affirmée de manière rassurante pour
l'ensemble des français
le deuxième point et qui va être le
point important aujourd'hui c'est est ce
que ces annonces seront financés et on
voit bien qu'elles ne le sont pas ce
premier ministre est de droite et bien
moi je réponds qu une politique que
conduit le chef du gouvernement edouard
philippe qui fait plus de dettes plus
d'impôts plus de déficit public plus de
dépenses publiques ça n'est pas vraiment
une politique de droite que nous avons
un sujet de finances publiques
absolument majeur rien aujourd'hui dans
le discours du premier ministre ne
garantit que l'on fasse les efforts
nécessaires pour redresser la situation
des finances publiques ça veut dire que
c'est sur les générations futures que
continuera à peser le poids des impôts
et dépenses puisqu'elle augmente la
dépense de l'état
elle a augmenté en 2018 les déficits de
l'état ils sont plus importants que
jamais la dette et les plus importantes
que jamais tous ces sujets c'est des
sujets qui sont attentatoires au pouvoir
d'achat des français a quand même un
décalage entre les discours qu'on entend
et les actes sur la réforme des
retraites on a eu finalement une
entourloupe du gouvernement
au départ il était question de ne pas
toucher à l'âge de 76 ans et maintenant
on nous parle d'un âge déquilibre on est
dans une sorte de spectre du parti
unique aujourd'hui prétendre que
lorsqu'on s'oppose au président de la
république c'est contraire aux intérêts
de son pays il y aurait les soutiens du
président de la république et les autres
y aurait pour le bien du pays
et puis les autres qui seraient les
ennemis de la france mais c'est une
conception invraisemblable
[Musique]